lui poitrenaud fait désormais partie de
l'histoire de tours ce tourangeau a
prêté ses traits au personnage
emblématique du père goriot j'aurais
quand même drôle j'ai surtout peur je me
ressemble bien
eugène de rastignac l'abbé birotteau
dénonce célèbre de la comédie humaine
inventé par balzac au début du 19e
siècle et transposé à l'époque moderne
l'anachronisme est une manière de rendre
hommage à ce travail là et de le
transporter dans notre temps à nous donc
il était évident que signac était par
exemple pour un signal que le père
gorrite et des personnages recchi qui
s'était aussi parmi nous aujourd'hui
cinq statues en bronze reproduite à
partir de vrais modèles et qui feront
désormais partie du décor de la ville
qui aura vu naître honoré de balzac dans
ses romans les plus célèbres on retrouve
certains lieux tourangeaux qui l'ont
marqué comme la pension vauquer ou
encore la cathédrale saint gatien
c'est un enfant du pays honoré de balzac
on sait il y avait qu'une dizaine
d'années me le revenus sans avant
touraine et il a écrit beaucoup de
romans où il s'est inspiré de
personnages de lieux qu'il a connu dans
son enfance donc c'est extrêmement
important pour l'identité de notre ville
en terme d'image et c'est extrêmement
attractif une façon pour le public de
découvrir ou de redécouvrir l'oeuvre de
l'écrivain une grande fresque et qui
dépeint très bien effectivement des
caractères des personnages très très
typé de leur tante cette figure de
l'homme qui travaille énormément
ça c'est une chose que l'on connaît
quasiment tous
c'est intergénérationnel plusieurs
charles connaissent c'est généralement
une chose qu'on transmet mais c'est
écrit même peut-être que c'est ce qu'on
connaît le moins finalement cette année
ont célébré à tour le 220e anniversaire
de balzac